Think your colon needs cleansing?
Chances are, it doesn’t.
And you’re probably doing more harm than
good.
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and there’s
a small but persistent population of people
out there who believe that regular colon cleansings
are good for your body.
Whether it’s laxatives, enemas, or an actual
colon irrigation - performed by a medical
practitioner.
The idea, they say, is that “it cleans out
all of the toxins that build up on the walls
of your colon over time” - preventing symptoms
like fatigue, bloating, and even depression
or cancer.
It’s true, there are instances where this
kind of procedure is warranted - for example,
someone who’s about to undergo a colonoscopy.
But the vast majority of the people who did
it, don’t actually need it - and over time,
they could be doing more harm than good.
The truth is, your body already has mechanisms
built in, specifically designed to eliminate
harmful substances.
Your liver and kidneys are two of those mechanisms.
Plus, there just isn’t enough research yet
on most colon cleanses, to really recommend
them to anyone who doesn’t have a specific
medical need.
Not to mention the fact that they have been
known to cause some very serious side effects.
Certain herbal cleanses, for example, have
been linked to liver toxicity and aplastic
anemia, which is a rare disorder where your
body stops producing enough red blood cells.
Other reports have specifically linked colonics
to things like abdominal pain, diarrhea, and
in more serious cases - kidney problems, heart
failure, and life-threatening infections.
Any scenario where you’re inducing diarrhea
- also carries the risk of disrupting your
body’s electrolyte balance, leading to a
number of health problems.
And that’s especially true for people with
kidney disease or heart problems - who ALREADY
have trouble maintaining proper fluid balance.
The same goes for pregnant and breastfeeding
women, people with GI problems - like Crohn’s
disease or ulcerative colitis - and people
with connective tissue disorders or severe
hemorrhoids, who run an increased risk of
bowel perforation.
For the general population, though, who has
no known health issues - it’s just not a
good idea to disrupt the natural balance of
bacteria in your gut.
It’s like taking antibiotics for a common
cold - yeah, you might get rid of bad bacteria,
but you’re also getting rid of good bacteria
- which puts you at a higher risk for future
infections.
Some people also like to claim that colon
irrigation is a good method for weight loss
- which isn’t exactly true.
A 2004 study on colonics, found the average
weight loss of patients to be around 2.6 lbs,
or 1.2 kg.
Not really a huge difference.
Not to mention that all you’re disposing
of, is extra water and stool.
You’re not permanently getting rid of any
fat, so all of that weight will come back
within a couple week’s time.
Most doctors say that if you’re really interested
in cleaning out your colon, the best thing
you can do is adjust your diet and make sure
to get plenty of exercise.
Processed foods, meat, and sugar will only
induce build-up, but foods that are rich in
fiber - like fruits and vegetables - will
pretty much do all of the work for you.
I know there’s a big debate about this online,
so which side are you on?
Are you a proponent of regular colon cleansing?
And if so, what are you experiences with it?
Feel free to let us know your thoughts in
the comments down below.
And as always, thank you guys for watching!